you were cut out of Justice League okay  listen I mean it's not not to be mean  because I love you and I think you're  fantastic and I want to know is your  character that was because they have so  many characters they took you out of  Justice League are you gonna get to play  that character somewhere else or imagine  if I said no imagine if I was like I'm  cut out of the whole thing we talked  about it though before so that's not  gonna happen I am gonna be in the flash  you're gonna be in the flash  yeah I'm iris West why are you staring  at me like that because you're the guest  you're sitting right here so that's how  it goes I asked your questions and then  turned away are you gonna be in the new  Justice League  [Laughter]  you're taking my shine hey look it's the  voice now now I'm here to judge you  you